la infancia otra de las víctimas de los
brutales ataques de rusia sobre ucrania
en kharkiv la segunda ciudad más grande
del país muchos sobreviven en los fríos
resguardos subterráneos
si suena una sirena hay que bajar
inmediatamente al refugio si oyes
disparos es mejor bajar también si por
ejemplo estamos fuera yendo a casa y
oímos disparos es mejor bajar el refugio
o ir a casa y quedarse en el pasillo
esos son los dos lugares más seguros más
o menos
millones de menores han huido del país
con sus familias desde el inicio de la
guerra hay más de 52 millones de
refugiados ucranianos según acnur los
que quedan cuentan su día a día bajo las
bombas
durante la semana por la mañana voy a
casa a hacer los deberes luego vuelvo
aquí a comer a jugar a las cartas con el
móvil a los juegos de mesa así todos los
días
según las autoridades ucranianas al
menos 215 niños y niñas han perdido la
vida consecuencia de los ataques del
kremlin desde el pasado 24 de febrero y
son casi 400 los que han resultado
heridos pero son pierden y en los
primeros días no estaba demasiado
preocupado porque no entendía realmente
lo que estaba pasando solo pensaba que
no era real y que acabaría al día
siguiente más tarde me di cuenta de que
no terminaría al día siguiente naciente
sin sustentación para miles de niños
especialmente las localidades del este
del país donde se están viviendo los
combates más violentos su cotidianidad
ha cambiado las clases son ahora por
internet eso cuando consiguen señal sin
embargo tienen la esperanza de un pronto
fin las guerras y ciudades al año voy a
pedir un deseo para mi cumpleaños o para
año nuevo que esta guerra termine lo
antes posible creo que la guerra no
terminará de inmediato pero si dentro de
unas semanas aunque tan para un golpe ya
tenga con sexo un deseo infantil que se
aleja de la pesadilla que se vive en su
país